buster's top ram
so he's let all the boys out finn bar
and my three ram lambs
hello
it's a beautiful sunny day i'm setting
up the electric fence for the horses
so they're gonna have this field
i'm gonna bail graze them through this
field through the winter
you can see the electric fence there
so i'm gonna let them through gate one
of my primitive gates that are right
there
hey alfie you got left behind
yeah everybody else is gone
for arthritic alfie except he has
a good life here
his shoulders are arthritic
so he walks with a funny gait now
hey you alfie
brindle leaving me you good boy
he's an old man now
all your buddies have gone up over the
hill yeah i know
you're gonna go join them
you've chosen a lovely sunny spot cozy
and warm
now to let the horses through
who are anticipating it
you can see they're waiting they've
figured out
i'm gonna be letting them through here
this little gate
you can see there's the owl box
up in the oak tree one of them
okay girls and boy i'm gonna let you out
okay now it's very slippy
oh gosh i don't want to fall underneath
galloping horse's hooves
they're not going far because they only
they can only graze a bit of grass
at a time and that makes it last through
the winter
so they're already coming back
so they've got a good length of grazing
they're annoyed that they don't have as
far to gallop
maya come here come on you two
come on good girls come on
there's the rams
in the same field but they get to free
range
because the horses are heavier beasts so
we'll cut up the soil
so that's why they're only given
sections
snorting
good girl come on leave it leave it
leave it
good girl maya leave it
you're so thrilled with the new place to
graze
cutting it all up now ladies
inca no leave them be
so they'll only get a section at a time
just so they don't tear the whole field
up
piece by piece also having the horses
out gives the dug
dung beetles winter feeding
oh she's very frustrated she didn't get
more
inca leave it
come back here come here you bold pup
come on come here
you're bold no lee inca
leave them good girl come on
look at that gala rearing
definitely frustrated they can't get
more of a gallop in
but i also don't want them to burst
their lungs because they haven't had
the space for a real gallop and a horse
can
burst their lungs if they suddenly are
given too much space when they've been
confined for so long in small spaces
the weather's been miserable so it's
really been really really mucky out
which is why they've been confined in
small spaces
come down to your side in a minute okay
big fella
this is one of my more primitive
homemade gates
we're above the large trees and the line
of beech trees
this is the top field or what we call
the wind charger field
because there used to be a wind charger
right there that's how my mother
grew up with electricity and it used to
flicker
if the wind was not consistent
so they still had gas lights or kerosene
lights
so here's the first bale for the horses
and i'm gonna let them through and
hopefully they've had a little bit of a
gallop
hopefully they won't do a huge
secondary gallop um
actually no you know what i'm gonna wait
till later today
to let them down to this section
no
no i'm going to let them through now i'm
going to let them through now
because where they're grazing now will
over the winter months will become one
of the muckiest areas
so may as well let them into this green
there's plenty of grass
for them to eat in amongst the leaves
and then out there around the bale so
when the grass is gone they graze the
bale
then i put another bale and then that
next section
and then when that's gone i put another
bale here then there
then there and the next section there
there
there and that's how so that this end of
the field
will be growing grass again
and will be green by the time the horses
are in this section
so that's a form of bale grazing it
makes it so the dung beetles have food
through the winter those that are flying
about the winter dung beetles as sally
anne mentioned there are
and it also keeps the horses outside
and healthy and fed
so yeah i'm gonna let the horses through
now
come on
[Music]
inca maya no
come on inca leave it
maya oh my lips are so cold and dry they
can't whistle
at a girl good girl good maya
clever pup never
yes you clever girl
so that's the beginning of
winter bale grazing for the horses and
how they help the farm
they'll manure that area the hay will
fertilize the area and seed the area
and i'll throw seed out there as well
to add to the diversity
and they're lovely and calm which is
good
so no lungs will get blown out that's
the scary thing with horses is
if they've been confined to barracks due
to the really mucky wet weather
and you let them out into a big space
they could gallop for glee and burst
their lungs
or burst along so it's always better to
let them out slowly yep here we go no
she's not going to jump the fence
maybe i spoke too soon maya
maya no maya good girl
well settle down no burst lungs today